good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 3456 object
class Keter special containment
procedures SCP 3456 is currently
uncontained all attempts to contain or
neutralize it have failed research into
methods for containment are ongoing
personnel who observed the entity are to
be treated with class GM mystics and
must be located with the least one
freshwater stream river or lake within
one kilometer of the treatment facility
all historical references to SCP 3456
are to be removed hand or attributed to
myth shell-shocked PTSD and hysteria
reports regarding loss of life and
damage as a result of SCP 3456 incidents
should be scrubbed of all references to
the anomaly and replaced with narratives
involving military conflict natural or
man-made disasters regions in which SCP
3456 are likely to appear are to be
monitored regularly personnel are to be
deployed to aid evacuation efforts in
the event of an incident direct
observation of SCP 3456 should be
avoided description SCP 3456 are a group
of quadrupeds resembling horses and
other equina Lynn Stinson deviates
significantly from other equites
particularly due to the lack of hair
presence of three-toed whose thick
translucent skin and either single or
multiple human torsos fused to its back
in addition to the normal acquainted
attached to the horse's body each torso
has a pair of arms and a head attached
where the arm span reaches twice the
height of the Anthony itself and end in
five sharpened protruding bone digits in
place of human fingers in most instances
SCP 3456 possesses a hole where a human
nose is normally located and is capable
of emitting high-pitched screams up to
110 decibels in intensity the size of
each SCP 3456 instance varies with the
largest recorded manifestation reaching
30 meters in height and 15 meters in
length as CP 34 56 instances thus far
have proven to be impervious to
conventional weapons instances
materialized near the sites of war
terrorist attacks natural disasters
multiple manifestations may occur
depending on the scale of the event as
indicated by the entity's
materialization during numerous
historical events throughout the 19th
20th and 21st centuries SCP 3456
instances display high levels of
adaptive intelligence during incidents
often engineering situations to trap or
torture their targets due to this it is
currently theorized that SCP 3456 may be
sapient direct observation of SCP 3456
by an individual will result in the
entity becoming aware of the observer at
which point it will display directional
awareness of said individuals at all
times SCP 3456 manifestations are known
to engage in predatory and stalking
behavior utilizing the environment to
conceal and camouflage themselves
survivors of such behavior report that
the entity will manipulate and follow
its targets pursuing them well beyond
the site of initial manifestation see
incident log I 34 56 32 SCP 34 56 will
continue such behaviors deliberately
exposing itself to as many individuals
as possible until it has captured a
large number of individuals at which
point it will dematerialize what happens
to subjects taken by SCP 3456 is
currently not known should SCP 3456 be
incapable of collecting a sufficient
number of subjects it will continually
materialize near individuals who have
observed it before until it is able to
capture them SCP 3456 is either
unwilling to cross or incapable of
crossing bodies of freshwater this was
initially discovered by fundation plants
within Basra Iraq during Operation Iraqi
Freedom Foundation agents were forced
into rapid retreat across the Tigris
River by three SCP 3456 manifestations
at which time they discovered that the
instances either could not or would not
set foot onto the bridge how and why SCP
3456 is unable to cross such geographic
boundaries is currently unknown the
following section contains journal
entries from Dave harkened an infantry
man from the British Expeditionary Force
during World War one
this journal describes several SCP 3456
sightings over the course of the Battle
of the Somme these journal entries will
be converted into audio files by acid
June 27th 1916 finally arrived at the
front picked up this little journal
while I was in Paris figured I might as
well keep record of my heroics on the
battlefield quite chuffed to finally be
in action though it seems I'm the only
one
most of these blokes have been fighting
for a couple of months now
they look downright dreadful but all
over the uniform their faces are so pale
looks like they haven't eaten or slept
for months commanding officer is rather
[ __ ] hot for battle
it's quite admirable July 2nd 1916 woke
in the early hours of the morning ground
was shaking Dom Nia shook me out onto
the muck on the dugout floor poor blokes
in the bunks on the other side looked
like they'd seen a ghoul pair of
Northern Irish lads from the kitcheners
armies if I remember right kept
muttering about a bucket II must be some
mixing were both gripping a gold
crucifix was about to lay my head back
down and get a wink of shall high when I
ended up scrambling into the mud loudest
damned thing I'd ever heard thought it
was the Hun artillery about to mark us
with a whiz bang and the problem was
they did get the bang this morning asked
our brass about the artillery barrage he
gave me a funny look and asked what the
bloody hell I was talking about
July 2nd 1916
we went looking for the dud that must
have come down last night didn't find it
but found something even the army
Walla probably can't explain strangers
looking crater I've ever seen was shaped
like a giant hoof July 3rd 1916 Huns
made a push today first time they've
moved in our region first time I'd ever
seen combat it's not romantic and
adventurous it's terrifying and deadly
my hands can't stop shaking already
messed up the chit once the Huns had our
outfit have against a wall damn near
over Alice didn't help that it rained
the night before making our foxhole
filled to the brim with muck one of the
fritz came right at me
I put one right between his eyes fell
right at the edge over the trench had to
look him in the eyes
poor lad couldn't have been more than 17
or 18 Martin one of those Irish lads is
gone was unlike anything I'd ever seen
one moment he's standing shooting at the
Huns all of a sudden the mud starts
boiling or anyone can react mud just
flies everywhere everyone else is
suddenly knocked down off their feet I
look up the wankers just gone there
weren't even body parts left haven't
told anyone but I'd swear that there was
bones coming up from underneath him
right before the mud went flying his
mate Brendan was digging in the mud for
hours looking for the crucifix July 14th
and 15th 1916 Hans tried to push back
this morning in the rain I was in the
machine-gun nest with Brendan the other
Irish chap at my unit they kept coming
and coming and getting stuck in the mud
hell I just kept shooting Sun is rising
I'm on watched till 8:00 at least that's
what the brass had said I started losing
track of how much time's been passing
there's something out there
something lurking out in the mud the
dead Huns nearly dozed off last night
listening to the moans of the bloody
wounded stuck out in no-man's land
poor bastards got left behind
saw something out of the edge of my
vision yes
something big couldn't quite make it out
it was much darker than usual overcast
sky was obscuring the full moon had a
couple of screams but whatever it was
was gone before my flare hit the sky
July 30th 1916 I've been seeing them at
the edge of my vision ever since that
first night a huge they moved so damn
fast they're gone before I can get a
clearer look or at least that's how it
was mucking out until today thick fog
and mist rolled in this warming
blanketed everything we figured the Huns
might use it to launch another push
bastards have been pushing non-stop
since the 20th saw it through the fog
looked like a shadow hiding in the mist
some sort of horse-like creature but
something dragging along the ground and
a giant lump where the rider would sit
said the lump started moving could have
sworn it was a person or something that
looked like a person sat up and the
things dragging along the ground reached
out in front of it and picked up
something thought it was a couple dead
Jerry's until they started scouring me
I'll never figure the noise it made
louder than a banshee shrill and twisted
it looked right at me two pairs of red
glowing orbs August 15
Brendan calls them love levees won't
tell me much more than that beginning to
understand while these blokes look so
terrified when I first arrived
auguste 13th bloody hell
bloody hell their nightmares been on
watched two nights in a row one just
appeared right there right in front of
me twenty feet had to be at least 20
feet away towered into the sky got my
flare to go off in time to see it pick
up a couple of wounded Jerry's in the
mud they don't have bloody skin it's
just muscle and fat the thing on its
bank who wasn't you it's no way it could
be human had no skin either no legs just
merged straight into the horse of the
stomach I took a couple of shots at it
with my rifle did absolutely nothing
like I was shooting it with a slingshot
it stopped soon as my flare reached its
highest point and turned looked straight
down at me both the horse and the thing
on its back it's mild or was 17th 1916
and assigned Night Watch for the past
four nights straight tried to tell the
brass hat about the knuckle ladies that
believed me
said it was the shell-shocked playing
with my head I had to put a sock in it
and keep on it kept coming back every
night same spot 20 feet from me picks up
wounded Jerry's turns and looks and it's
gone it's playing with me
I'm sure of it last night there was
another one two four of those things on
its back
they're the same damn thing 7:00 a.m.
August 20th 1960 Jerry's made a big push
back yesterday rained two days ago all
day so the muck was deep we were on
machine come again in the pillbox so
many of them in no-man's-land last night
couldn't tell the dead from the living
haven't slept in 6 days there were five
tonight three of them had more than one
of those things on their back the one
that keeps coming back dropped something
so it shine in the flare light 10 a.m.
August 20th 1916 went out into the mud
where it appears every night found
marked crucifix that didn't hat August
20th 1916 they're getting bold saw one
out in broad daylight pretty sure it was
the same one heard itself in the mud
just lying there waiting there going
over the top of three there are more out
there now all doing the same thing god
help us
official records show that david
harkened was declared missing in action
on August 20th following a failed
British counter-attack against the
German trenches additional queries have
revealed that one Brendan O'Malley
within the same unit was also reported
missing in action on the same date
Harkins journal was found 20 feet from
the edge of the German trenches two
months after he disappeared
incident log i 34 56 32 the following
incident details an SCP 3456 manifest
station in Fukushima Japan following the
2011 earthquake several foundation
reconnaissance teams were deployed
following the evacuation of the city to
assess whether or not the earthquake had
been caused by an anomaly SCP 3456
manifested in several locations during
and shortly after the quake resulting in
2562 missing persons
foundation reconnaissance personnel were
not expected to encounter a CP 3456 as
manifestation had ceased in the
prohibited zone 64 hours after the
majority of the civilian population was
evacuated incident log I 34 56 32
playing log now forward reconnaissance
teams were deployed in squads of four
with one member of each team possessing
helmet-mounted camera equipment the
following log details the events
surrounding squad three three of the
eight teams were noted to have
encountered a CP 3456 however the
cameras four squads 1 and 6 were
destroyed early during interaction with
SCP 3456
entities this is an audio feed between
squad 3 and command other members of the
squad were not subject to audio
communications between commander Brian's
and the communications officer again log
the helmet mounted cameras switched on
as the reconnaissance squad departs the
helicopter transport history depicted
both in front and behind the unit as the
camera swerves with the operatives head
is noted to have sustained significant
structural damage with many visible
points where the concrete has buckled or
split apart
this is a reconnaissance squad three
orange leader commandeer rate we read
you argue later the feed turns to the
left and the right noting to other
individuals each equipped with standard
field agent equipment Mic Check
Lopez reporting check check this thing
working reading you loud and clear come
on des
Bryan's is seen pointing at the screen
command is the camera and Breyers helmet
transmitting we're getting clear
transmissions from the camera navigation
is sending you coordinates
they just Lopes and cellos being
provided Kent counters remember any
deviation from the norm is grounds for
further investigation should you
encounter an anomaly Radio its location
and containment teams will be deployed
under no circumstances is your squad to
engage in anomaly from this point
forward communications with command will
be directed to you Roger commit the
camera tilts slightly downward pointing
at a square device called agent bias
wrist okay
our target is three klicks south will
have to move across the Arakawa River
here chow Lopez I want those cans
counters counting as we're moving the
moment those levels look weird you say
something got it
riders get close to me for the next 10
minutes squad 3 moves through five
blocks of damaged buildings and roadways
with no signs of anomalous activity
hey boss my counter just got a huge
spike my needle went all the way into
the red for about three seconds
Brian's holds his hand up to stop the
reconnaissance members stopped in the
street buyers moved slowly in a 360
degree arc as he attempts to locate the
source of the elevated Hume readings
command you got all that right we got it
orange later we're not picking up
anything on the visual or at this point
command noted the presence of a dull
rhythmic thumping noise intensity of the
thumps indicated a distance of roughly
300 meters between the source of the
disturbance and the camera's microphone
command please hold your position orange
later
the sound is noted to have grown
slightly louder and decreased in
distance from 300 to 250 meters away the
camera begins another 360 degree arc as
agent Byers
scans the surrounding environment the
noise abruptly ends after two minutes of
continuous increase in intensity at
crash is heard and the camera swivels
180 degrees Lopez's camp counter can be
seen on the pavement glass shattered we
might have a problem the camera pans up
from the camp counter on the ground and
captures SCP 3456 standing in an
intersection 200 meters away the camera
zooms in on the entity and command notes
the translucent skin and fused human
torso in the middle of the horse's back
it also appears to remain limp and
motionless for approximately 30 seconds
command believe we have identified the
entity responsible for the quake
negative orange later at CP 3456 is not
responsible for the earthquake Oh Donald
we have an SCP 3456 manifestation
what that's 34 56 what we're doing here
it also begins to move slowly
straightening into an upright position
its arms begin swinging damaging or
destroying several structures around it
and drawing Brian's attention orange
leader command has authorized a UAV
drone strike move your team out of the
street and into the high-rise two
buildings to your left
Roger commit the camera focuses on Brian
for another five seconds as he turns to
address the squad before focusing on the
entity at CP 3456
has stopped moving its arms the entity
turns towards the reconnaissance team in
the mid sailau vocalization for
approximately five seconds brian's
points to the side street and the camera
swivels in that direction bringing a
large high-rise into frame now the
camera begins to shake as it tilts down
as Briers briefly looks at the ground
before returning to a level view the
feed swivels to the left briefly and
captures the approaching UAV drum before
swiveling to the right the entity can be
seen charging towards the squad
appendages reaching towards the screen a
UAV drone is seen as a blur by the
camera and there is an explosion as the
entity emits a wail and disappears
beneath a cloud of smoke
well I kill it ready no George it only
flows it down the squad enters the
high-rise and begins climbing the stairs
a camera stops shaking as the squad
stops on the 8th floor of the building
Ricky why the hell is it here an
argument can be heard between the
communications officer and the head of
reconnaissance the screen begins
vibrating excessively and the sound of
SCP 3456 approaching the building can be
heard
Brian's is seen directing the squad
members to the door of the large utility
closet as Baez closes the door behind
them the video feed displays a shadow
blocking out the light of the window the
camera is switched temporarily to night
vision by bias a camera vibrates four
more times before the sound of SCP 3456
approaching stops the Anthony can be
heard breathing heavily outside the
window ready come in Ricky the
previously mentioned argument can still
be heard
damnit I wish we had a way to see what
that thing is doing up we do have a
camera I'm not sticking my head out
start that door hey this is the utility
closet right yeah fire there a broom in
here yeah
roll a copier toss me your helmet the
screen wobbles and is inverted as agent
Byers removes his helmet and hands it to
agent Chow the camera shakes several
times the click of a flashlight and the
sound of tape being torn can be heard
the feed stops shaking and there is a
tapping noise good
this should let us see what's going on
you got your remote display on right
I'll be over shoot it's doing out there
good thinking show whatever it is in the
feed wobbles back and forth and the
sound of the closet door creaking open
can be heard night vision is disabled as
the lens begins detecting light coming
through the window the entity's hands
grip the side of the windows and its
face comes into frame from the left its
eyes move back and forth several times
the entity breathes out briefly fogging
the lens of the camera it emits a
vocalization causing the camera to drop
to the floor the door is heard slamming
shut with the force of the vocalization
the entity lingers in the window for a
moment before releasing the sides and
disappearing from view SCP 3456 his
shadow begins moving away from the
building and out of the frame the camera
shakes and is slowly pulled back into
the utility closet the camera shakes for
60 seconds before it is handed back to
agent Pius
three minutes passed before SCP 3456 can
no longer be heard the other three squad
members appear visibly shaken by the
preceding events orange leader is your
squad still impact Reggie what the hell
is going on you and two of the other
squads have encountered SCP 3456 it
wasn't supposed to be here supposed to
be without confirmation George this line
is being monitored supposed to be here I
need to inform them you can't do that
orange leader the security clearance be
damned in the face do you think I give
about bureaucratic procedures right now
ten seconds of radio silence pause you
can't tell them what it is god damn it
Ricky
you can tell them what it doesn't like
five seconds of silence are you talking
about fresh water fifteen seconds of
silence that's helpful Reggie what are
we supposed to do
watch the bottle of water on it and
watch it melt George if you get to the
bridge over the arakawa we won't be able
to follow Bryan this looks down at the
display device on his wrist which lights
odd Reggie the crossing is still one
point five clicks away we'll never make
it there give me a second
thirty seconds pass in silence Brian's
display lights up again followed by
those of the other three squad members
the video feed tilts down your original
route took you across the arakawa of
stream in a narrow point aviary rather
due to a closer crossing at the river's
widest point about one kilometer out and
should take about 15 minutes if you use
buildings for cover the hello is already
on route
Roger command what's the status of the
two other teams with lost contact he
turns and looks in each member of the
group a fall facing bias Ezreal I need
you to poke your head out the door make
sure that thing is not there perspective
shifts slightly as by his looks out the
closet door SCP 3456 is not seen oh okay
so here's the deal folks we got
something out there that isn't supposed
to be here command has our evac on route
but we need to get over the our comm
well for them to do that any particular
reason for that
why can't they just pick us up here you
saw what it can do the man doesn't want
to risk a chopper getting knocked out of
the sky that thing it can't cross fresh
water the widest point of the river is
one kilometer south we stick to the
shadows and move fast and quiet that's
all you need to know for now brian's is
seen giving this signal to move out a
squad spends the next 15 minutes moving
between different buildings the squad
stops approximately 50 yards from the
bridge a few metres from a large
intersection the frame pans from left to
right in a 360 degree arc as Byers
surveys the surrounding buildings
there is no sign of SCP 3456
command for 50 yards from the bridge no
side of the entity the hello should be
on the bridge and you see it biased
turns to the front and the camera zooms
in capturing a ch-47 Chinook helicopter
on the bridge
Roger command we feared
sweet Mary Mother of Peters word David
the squad begins moving forward but
stops the camera experiences several
severe vibrations and a ticking noise
begins as Chou's can't counter buzzers
in alarm SCP 3456 emerges from the
street to their left five meters ahead
and turns so that it directly faces the
reconnaissance squad it also leans down
on the right side and both the horse and
the human torso emit a vocalization from
the bridge small arms fire can be heard
and seen colliding with Antony's skin
two RPGs collide with the entity along
its neck to no effect the camera moves
down to Bryan's who pulls two canisters
from his belt stun grenades Bryan's
flips the pin on the grenades and looks
back to the squad Bryan's throws the
grenade into the air and begins running
forwards baez looks down to avoid the
flash there is a bang and the entity is
heard wailing Baez looks back up Lopez
and Bryan's in the scene in front
they've nearly reached the bridge a
camera turns slightly to the left and
Chao can be seen running alongside Byers
the feed suddenly spent by his level
with the ground and begins sliding
backwards the camera lifts up and bias
can be heard screaming
perspective tilts up and shows the
entity's hand wrapped around by his left
leg by his head tilts back to a more
level angle depicting his ascent into
the air as he continues screaming the
camera stops moving up and focuses on
SCP 3456 his face at which time it is
noted to be smiling the lens attempts to
focus on something embedded within the
entity's forehead and zooms in a golden
crucifix and a world war one British
infantry helmet can be seen before on
the camera terminates and lock post word
timestamps from the visual footage
indicate that a CP 3456 D manifested at
the termination of the video feed agents
Andrew Byers had Liao's onchao have been
declared missing and remain unaccounted
for interesting thing to note the people
that survived that log they you all just
listen to probably not even the scariest
thing they seem in Japan some of the
stuff over there is insane but I digress
I think that about does it for today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert James
Sabah Kareem el ash Mui Justin day
Thomas Morin Curie kuma and jayvo Jack
crystal spice goddess of Donuts my
archive curator Nick Joseph Lewis ooh
agent vamp King modding the wanderer and
dr. Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
you